and i believe it's from doing
you know opiates for 20 years it took to
get that condition you know to go away
now you don't have the you know
you're not you can't do opiates for 20
years and expect to just walk away from
it
so
that's that but so you know
does it matter i don't know i feel like
it does i feel like it's it was it was
you know they're
self-medicating and i believe i had
every right to do it and i believe also
that i did not ever break the law
you know and i have a perfect record to
show for it so the opiates help you with
this condition this is a psychological
condition yeah it's a um
it is a it's called trichotril anemia
and it's an obsessive compulsive
personality disorder where you pull your
hair out
and
i don't say eat the hair follicle but
it's the whole thing you put it in your
mouth and you and it's the way that i
assess whether the hair follicle is
healthy or sickly and if it's healthy
i'm depressed i'd pull it out if it's
sickly i'm happy to pull out it's almost
like pruning really i mean
i don't know what how it you know that's
how kind i processed it
but we tried everything to stop and
nothing worked i mean my whole life i
had bald spots in my head you know the
vacuum caught on fire filled up with
hair so much hair
and and so much that i would get scar
tissue and it wouldn't grow back and i
had to get hair implants
and i pulled those out even some of them
and then i pulled the sutures out and
then i went and had the doctor sew it
back up and then i pulled the sutures
back out again i was so embarrassed i
had my friend sew it up with a needle
and thread so if i ever shaved my head
bald i i would look like a
you know a monster
and um i have so much scar stuff going
on so
you know it was a pretty debilitating
affliction really i mean especially
being um you know a rock and roller
in the 80s and um
you're a musician yeah musician and
that's when it started i'll never forget
the day i pulled like a whole clump of
my hair came out and um
i was just devastated you know i
and um i was not wanting to go bald
that's for sure i've identified my whole
life with my hair i even prayed to god
that i would have good hair when i was a
child for whatever reason
and um
and you know it's something that i'm
part native american indian maybe that
has something to do with it too i don't
know but it's something that matters to
me
and you know what i hear an interesting
factoid that i just heard recently that
that makes a lot of sense to me in that
one of the wars i think it was vietnam
they employed native americans for both
uh you know
translator like encrypting you know
messages because of their language but
also
for
tr for
tracking or trapping you know for
because they were good animal trackers
trappers and um
and so they were able to you know find
like presumably people or or maybe um
weapons caches or something in the
jungle they're very good at it but when
they got them in the army and they
shaved their head they lost their
abilities
to do so so their hair was directly tied
to their intuition i guess their their
their skills when it come when it came
to tracking
um in the jungle so
you know i certainly uh subscribe to
that theory as
having some sort of validity i because
i'm very psychic i do tail readings and
and um
i didn't ever consider that it
necessarily had anything to do with my
hair but i have not
shaved it to be able to test the theory
so
but the heroin use
fixed the condition the opiate use did
because i and i like to say heroin
because i i used a variety of of of
opioids and heroin is just a brand name
from bear you know and um
and it has such a negative connotation
to it that um
uh it was you know
a variety of different kinds the very
first time i ever did opiates like okay
and one of the other things people with
trickle chill they don't experience the
euphoria that people get from taking the
drug
which i don't either and
but i know what that euphoria is i
experienced it two times
and once was the first time i took
opioids i took uh three vicodin 750s
and i was in la la land for like 12
straight hours
before and i
only experienced that one more time
since and
and that was for a condition i had that
was um
sciatic nerve that i had for like five
years
and this was terrible it was incredible
pain i had to
sleep in weird positions and i'd be
walking and just hit that nerve and drop
to the ground have my girlfriend have to
carry me out
and
tell me she didn't want to have kids
with me because i'd be having to play
with a cane you know
but i went to um
i i went to every doctor
orthopedist physical therapist
acupuncture i'm sorry acupressure
um chiropractic
chiropractor i went in there with a back
problem and i left with a neck and a
back problem
but
um i spent every penny i had and they
didn't do anything for me i was just
gonna maybe get the surgery where they
cut into you and all this and i said
well let me try one more thing i haven't
tried acupuncture
so i went to this
guy this chinese guy and dr chen i think
his name was and he stuck all these
needles in me and hooked up electricity
and something ringing
i'm like oh my god the first time i went
it made it worse
and the second time i went made it 50
better third time i went it fixed it i
went one more time i've never been back
since it was a miracle like 250 bucks
where five grand couldn't fix me with
the other doctors
and um
i swear it was a miracle so but
prior to going to the acupuncture it was
vicodins and flexurals muscle relaxers
the only thing that would work because
the
muscle would tighten it pinched the
nerve and the more it pinched the nerve
the more it hurt the more the muscle
tightened so you had to break that that
cycle and
and so that was my first you know
introduction to opiates and and like i
said it's difficult to do it for any
experi any length of time and not
develop a dependency on it
you ultimately are creating more uh
you know
receptors
in your brain and um
you know becomes exceedingly more
difficult to feel normalized um the
longer you've done them so
and that's in
the trickle trill it was just basically
a kind of a consolation to the whole
thing i didn't start off
knowing that there was a correlation
between the two i ended up reading about
it and um
and then um just i think as as a
consequence
i one day just didn't pull my hair out
anymore it was amazing i mean
and um i believe it had to do with the
the opiate use i believe that i was
ultimately intuitively
knowing what needed to be done and
i self-medicated and i don't believe i
have every i believe i have every right
to not be in pain and misery
and i don't think i broke the law once
and i have a perfect criminal record to
show for it yeah you're not homeless
living in a tent on skid row you're
you're living a fairly normal life oh
yeah i never
i mean i i never stole and did all that
i paid i paid my own way and i
functioned i worked for years and years
and years as a dj in a strip club
actually made me probably better dj
but um
you know yeah i didn't experience a lot
of like i argued with the guy in rehab
once the counselor was talking about
other stuff he did
and i just never did any you know stole
from your grandmother and
you know all these
horrible things people talk about i mean
i didn't do any of that
and didn't reach i guess those kind of
depths and lows that people talk about
um i didn't buy anything off the streets
you know and um
you know
not that
trying to suggest that i'm better in any
way than other people who have gone to
those extremes i mean everybody lives
the life that they uh
you know that they live and learn from
from all of all the things and all
experiences so i learned a hell of a lot
from mine you know it's funny because
i was the most anti-drug person in the
world um i remember
my first girlfriend who i was in love
with um
she had a drug problem and i had never
done drugs and
i was talking to her getting on her
about her drug problem and giving her a
hard time about it and
one day she goes matt you know i would
rather
do drugs and die young then and be happy
have people like me than be like you and
never do drugs
and have people afraid of you when they
walk it when you walk in the room and at
that time i was having a real hard time
with the effect i was having on people
you know everywhere i went smile what's
the matter can't be that bad
you know and i'm like why am i having
this negative effect on people
everywhere and and so it really hit me
at that point you know i couldn't agree
with her more and i've said okay
you know i had always said that if i was
going to get any karma from that
relationship
because i broke up with her ultimately
for a drug problem that i was going to
develop a drug problem it was my karma
for having so little empathy for hers
and as far as i'm concerned that's
exactly what had happened
but you know i i don't like to that was
a
brief period of time in my life that
or how should i frame this i don't like
to highlight that it's like you know
like to where it's going to be this big
focal point i mean it's a it's a it's
just one aspect of my life one small
part of my life that
that um had its place and i'm
off to bigger greener pastures so
um
you know
i don't make any excuses for it i
believe that it was necessary and i
believe that i'm better off for it
i don't have all these um you know woe
me you know you're a functional heroin
addict sorrow stories um
yeah again i don't those are words i
don't choose to use because like i said
heroin is a brand name from bear and i
used all forms of opiates um
you know it wasn't if i if i did if i
used
heroin it would i smoked it and i never
shot it and
um also um
you know it was pills or
or um
you know there was a liquid coating i
think and um you know whatever i
whatever i needed to at the time um
you know i've experimented with all all
kinds of drugs really i
try to stay away from
you know hallucinogenics um just
basically uh because of my
genetic um
you know my mother and my father seem to
have been quite a bit victims of
strong hallucinogenic drugs and and you
know when i was conceived
they had conceived me in an lsd orgy
and when my
when when i was in the womb my mother
continued to do lsd she said and
sang and danced and ate saltine crackers
and did lsd while i was in the womb
so as a result i believe i was born with
a highly active pineal gland that
excreted dmt into my sleep and gave me
what are called today night terrors
where you
hallucinate when you dream basically
with your eyes open which is dmt high so
i had hundreds of dmt highs before the
age of puberty naturally i believe
and let me tell you
those are some unique experiences i mean
you can say that they're just um
chemical induced random
you know events but
there were things that i was given
information i had to look up in a
dictionary i can tell you i didn't know
these things you can believe me or you
don't but i know i did not know these
things i had to look them up and i wrote
a book about them actually some of them
you know there were some really pleasant
experiences but the overwhelming
majority of them were horrific actually
in fact um
one
led me to be a vegetarian because i mean
it
you know i was in the presence of what
two i guess reptilian aliens that poured
some fluid on some guy's head and melted
his skin off and it created an emotion
that went beyond fear and horror in the
traditional sense that's for sure and i
thought
you know that's evil what they're doing
they seem to be getting pleasure out of
it like
maybe when we burn in that with
magnifying glass
i thought well if that's evil humans
shouldn't be treated like cattle
maybe cattle shouldn't be treated like
cattle
and that led me to be a vegetarian so
from this horrific probably the most
terrifying experience of my life
my heart nearly and that's the thing
okay my eyes are open and i'm seeing
this in front of me and my heart is
racing jumping out of my chest
can you tell me what's different
from that experience than
if it was an actual real experience
i mean it's about as real as real gets
and um but from that
horrible you know night terror came what
i believe
is this extremely positive you know
thing in my life that
if you just calculate how many
animals now have not had to be murdered
or killed or whatever for my my diet for
my food
three a day maybe breakfast lunch and
dinner for
20 years
i mean that's a significant impact on on
earth i think
so
again i i don't feel like a victim or
any have any regrets i'm i
i really like who i am i love myself and
i'm happy
most of the time
and i'm happy to be me so so tell me you
spoke a little bit about your mom tell
me about your father you you you believe
your father is charles manson
yeah well
i've done um
the math on it certainly it sure does
lend itself to it and then i've done
some dna tests and um
i did a test with my half-sister rebecca
and that came back positive and the only
thing in common we have is our is
charles charles manson and um her mother
hung out with my mother
with them and um i did a test
with the alleged grandson
that was featured on cnn it came back
negative and
everyone was like oh that proves he's
not
related but
turns out he wasn't related to charlie
and that was just proven recently in a
probate
uh hearing he was ordered to do a test
by the courts and refused
and then i did a test with charlie's dna
where it was smuggled out by an
individual
um
and that those results
they said we're pining over the
information now we'd like to say it was
positive but we can't there's another
dna contaminant
and i said only one other person touched
that wristband as it was
they said we'll send their dna and we'll
make a match we'll figure it out so i
sent it in
marlin's dna and they said they didn't
have enough
original dna to do it so
that was where that was left so i don't
have any direct
proof uh
from him
um
but i do believe that that matched that
with my half-sister
enough for me to
to get the closure that i wanted and and
um
then there's another thing going on too
that i think will kind of wrap it up
beyond any shadow of doubt that i'm
going to leave um
right now for a future date until i get
all the pieces together and the facts
together um has to do with ancestry.com
and um i'm working on a documentary and
i'll have that in the documentary as you
certainly look like your alleged father
final yeah you know i can
you know
lie about a lot of things but that's
something that's been very difficult to
make up i look like it's twin and that's
even hard for me to deny i mean at this
point if it
you know if it wasn't true it would be
more shocking than if it was
that's the way i like to look at it but
you know dna is very complicated stuff
i've learned quite a bit about it and um
they really you know there's a thing now
called pioneer dna that that is um
where people have multiple codes and
and and as it turns out we've either
evolved to this point or i have always
been to this point but we it's now
believed that we have a variable genetic
matrix as opposed to the fixed genetic
matrix
thought to be for so long where you live
under say a power line electric power
line and you die of cancer from the
electromagnetic magnetic radiation but
your kids
will go have three generations later
have a dna that's more tolerant of it
and survive it you know that's called
natural selection i guess evolution
but now there's kids being born hiv
positive and
rendered negative through spontaneous
remission due to newly activated dna
four thousand times more resistant to
hiv in a single lifespan
even elephants that were slaughtered for
their tusks
half the population were wiped down 700
000 elephants elephants are being born
with no tusks
and that's not over 100 years that's
over 20 years since the poaching of
elephants so you got to imagine there's
something going on on a level that we
can't barely even
comprehend you know tell me about your
relationship with your mom
um i assume charles didn't raise you
what's that charles madsen didn't raise
you no i was adopted and um
to a very uh
very
healthy functional loving
family my father was a fireman he was a
hero in society and um
i think my lucky stars that i was um
raised by them
and um not
the other um in fact my mother said she
was um
kind of hung up on making the decision
to the very last minute she decided to
adopt me and um
she has been somebody that has been kind
of an enigma in my life i have not met
her i was going to meet her with
a girlfriend we were going to drive in
wisconsin meter and then she started
talking about
how the police play a game of bait where
they bring people they don't like and
turn them loose in indian cemetery and
give them 15 minutes and hunt them down
and
indians don't bury their dead they throw
sticks on them so it just looks like
dead indian land there and the feds
don't investigate because it's sovereign
indian land and
and we were just like wow i don't want
to get caught up in a good game of bait
so we decided not to go
and um i've heard they do chicago police
are
crazy um
and she
has exhibited some mental illness um
which you know i don't know why people
who are mentally ill always have to be
kind of wicked they can't just be happy
you know
mentally ill but
you know she's just said and done some
horrible things so i just had to cut her
off and and
you know it's unfortunate but
you know i don't have any relationship
with her
what age were you that you discovered
that you may be is charles manson's son
how old were you when you first realized
that you might might it was like
i think i was
25 or 29 or something like that it was
like 1997 i think do you identify with
them
what's that do you identify with with
madison as you are
um
i mean i do in terms of you know like
let me put you this way okay when i got
the first letter from him i was living
in mission hills right off the 118
freeway i was playing in a rock band
i was
you know
having sex with strippers i was doing
drugs and i was conspiring to take over
the world
and
i i'm i'm like man do i have any free
will at all you know i was always one of
these people that thought it was all
your environment that genetics meant
nothing it was your environment that
created who you were and um i had been
forced to
you know reconsider that and now i think
that you know
apple trees don't produce oranges and um
man genetics is a strong motivator in in
shaping who you are i mean i was living
his life you know pretty much i would
like to say think the good parts of it
and um i mean i could have moved
anywhere on planet earth i was born in
chicago and i moved in his backyard
2 000 miles away i moved right into his
backyard like what are the odds of that
you know what is that exactly you know
so i'm not i was never a fan or any
interested in being somebody's you know
follower or whatever you know i'm my own
man so
i'm proud it's my own fault probably but
um
you know
so that kind of bothered me a little bit
actually that i did have those kind of
you know similarities
um
very odd
but your life has not
come anywhere close to as
destructive self-destructive as is no no
absolutely not i mean i'm um
i say bugs drawn in the pool i'm i'm a
vegetarian because i don't want to hurt
animals and i go way out of my way to
really
think things through and make sure that
i fall on the right side of of right
wrong and things
i'm not the criminal type i don't harm
people and
consequently i don't
i don't play the victim i'm not a victim
either so
i feel like um
you know it's real important for me to
actually you know like i don't even lie
i don't like to lie i believe you
surrender your reality the person you
lie to the best
liars are those who believe their real
their lies and hence surrender their
reality so
i think it's good logic not to but it's
also something that's important to me to
to be an honest um
considerate compassionate empathetic
person
and in your life you've you've
other than working at strip club you're
a musician as well i am i have music in
52 countries i have two songs in rock
band video game i have two albums one
not a label in texas one in
italy
i have a soundtrack to a movie i did
called american crude with rob snyder
sony pictures
and um
i am uh very uh proud of what i've
achieved in with my music i have a
youtube channel one man's son
um
where i play a bunch of piano and i have
my videos and things up and um
you know music is my life it just
really uh makes my wheels turn i mean
and charles madison also was a musician
he was and my mother actually too was a
pianist actually one of my neighbors
where i live
took guitar lessons from charles manson
when he she was a kid
oh wow where in kentucky no this is in
uh
rustic canyon
in l.a oh wow
like three doors down was brian wilson's
house where all right brad wilson went
on tour and the manson clan
stayed in brian wilson's house yeah i
had a picture an original photograph
from him sitting in
in dennis's house playing guitar
and at one point
he was kind of getting weird with me in
the letters saying um
right now in his coattails or something
like that so
i sent him that picture and um
you know i'm like look if i was trying
to write on your coattails i'd be asking
you for photos not sending you photos
you know photos probably worth a lot of
money so i sent it to him and um
now i regret it because they probably
never got it guards probably got it or
something but
but uh otherwise i would still have that
i do have one original photo though of
him
that was left on my car
passenger seat once oddly enough after
it had been stolen but there is their
physical resemblance is remarkable i'm
sorry
the physical resemblance is remarkable
oh i know and that really hit me once um
especially with that particular photo i
mean my car had been stolen and they
found it in barstow the day of my
birthday actually i got it back
and i drove there and got it back cost
me a thousand bucks get my own truck
back and as i'm driving back i look over
and there's like crack pipes and
pictures and things and
some who stole it uh
and i flipped over this purse and there
was a signed autographed photo of him
sitting on the on the passenger seat and
there was something about the angle like
you were saying that you know the side
profile a little bit with the flared
nostrils because it's not a typically
caucasian trait to have flared nostrils
and um
and and i don't know the chest hair and
just the something about that photo i
was like oh my god man i mean
that really
hit me and it really kind of struck me
as this is definitely you know
is it is it something you're comfortable
with you're at peace with you're at
peace with it i mean it's been like a
hollywood movie it's been kind of um
surreal i have not personalized it much
i don't let myself
experience any emotions relative to it
[Music]
you know i can
love my mother and father
philosophically
i don't actually
have any
real feelings
i don't allow myself you know because
i mean what what greater
practical joke would that be to you know
if you believe that these are your
parents when they if it turned out not
to be i mean
so
you know
i didn't want to look like jason did
crying up there it was just something
that wasn't even real so i've kind of
you know and even still it's like
i feel i have closure like
like i guess
scientifically or statistically but i
don't feel like i have closure like
emotionally i guess
if that makes any sense yeah
and how do you know
i'm not even sure
i was born in 1968 so i'm 50 something
was that 52
i can't barely wrap my head around that
right now
like i don't know if i
hit my head and woke up one day and i
suddenly was you know
a decade went by i just it's hard for me
to wrap my head around my age you're
into tarot cards you mentioned i mean do
you feel like there's some kind
of connection that that exists between
you and
and manson
um
there was a time where there was i think
i experienced some really bizarre and
unique things relative to that that um
like some kind of psychic connection
definitely um i don't anymore i feel
like um
i feel like he's passed and he's gone
and i don't think he's lurking around at
all
um there were some strange events that
took place
immediately following uh his passing
um
when i was on the way actually to the
coroner's office to attempt to get
somebody um
so we could have a regular burial and
not have it cremated
um there's some really strange things
that were occurring that i believe were
related to him
but since then i haven't experienced
anything
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life most
important thing i've learned in my life
that's a good question
well i don't really have any regrets per
se
if
maybe the one regret i might have is not
taking my family for granted
i guess
um
and
i adopted family and
i don't think um i think i would have if
i had to do it all over again i would
have maybe done things differently and
stayed a little closer to home and and
appreciated
um
[Music]
having a family i guess
instead of taking it for granted
like i did and then all of a sudden the
day comes when they're gone and
that's that's been a rough one
all right matt thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome super
interesting thanks thank you very much
you